hello everyone and welcome to the moment
you've all been waiting for and for the
game you've all been waiting for it's uh
uh already versus yanni palmisi in round
two of the super bit chess classic uh
tournament uh this is classical chess so
we are going to analyze um a few lines
more than we would in a rapid or blitz
game but
it's a very important to understand all
the intricacies of the position as these
are uh incredible incredible positions
so you guys will enjoy the game uh it is
uh i believe alireza's first classical
game after uh reaching 2800 after that
the beautiful beautiful game where he
defeated shakhtar mahmoud
and of course you all know yan the
former world church championship
challenger two of them will also meet in
the next candidates tournament so this
is a nice warm-up for them
let's check it out that there is quite a
lot to enjoy so already with the white
pieces opens with e4 we have e5 by on
and already a very interesting um
development bishop the c4 he goes for
the bishop's opening knight to f6 bion
d3 and c6 now preparing to strike in the
center with d5 we have knight to f3 and
d5 now uh attacking the bishop here so
bishop to b3 and now well you could uh
play something like bishop to d6 bishop
to b for check these are the usual
replies uh uh nipple first starts with
a5 he wants to check how well it is uh
uh save the bishop will it be a3 will be
c3 would be a4 so all it is advances the
pawn all the way to a4 and only now
bishop to b for with check we have c3 uh
blocking check bishop back to d6 and now
e captures on d5 we have c captures and
bishop to g5 uh bishop to e6 nicely
continuing development and now knight to
a3 the knight cannot come to b5 as a5
has been played so b5 has been weakened
and there is no c pawn so once the
knight lands it's a
a very good square for the knight knight
beat the c7 uh and uh to d7 and now of
course knight to b5 attacking the bishop
but the knight has moved from v8 uh so
we have this square for our bishop we
have bishop back to b8 and the position
uh was already reached last year in the
norway norway chess tournament in an
armageddon game against um karjakin and
nepo here so alireza of course
knows about this game uh but in that
game karaoke played uh castles here and
that game ended by karjakin defeating
nipple but here we have d4 uh so the
game deviates from uh from that one uh
but it's still not new territory we have
e4 by nipple challenging the knight here
and now knight to d2 now all it is i
will play knight to f1 knight to e3 and
then the knight will be again nicely
played so here we have castles knight to
f1 uh h6 challenging the bishop bishop
to h4 and now bishop all the way to f4
we do
need control over that e3 square uh and
here there is a game where bishop to g3
was played that was played in 2019 uh
between orotovsky mikhail and evgeny
posney that ended in a draw but here we
have h3 by alireza and it is only now as
of move 16 that we have a completely new
game so now we are in uh
unexplored territory for us for the two
of them most likely not uh so here we
have rook to e8 by nipple and now comes
ponta g3 uh queen to e2 also could uh
can be played you develop the queen you
prepare knight to e3 the queen also as
defense you want to castle queen side as
soon as possible uh but alireza does not
see a castling queen side as
a necessity here in in this position so
g3 challenging the bishop bishop all the
way back to b8 it's a very nice square
for the bishop controls the knight and
all of the squares that the knight can
go to plus you're now threatening g5 to
trap the bishops while it is advances
the pawn to g3
uh now makes room for the bishop on g3
uh and now comes knight to f8 uh we have
knight to e3 finally and knight to g6
now attacking the bishop here and now
bishop captures an f6 this is a very
interesting decision bishop to g3 looks
a bit weird because you can allow bishop
captures on g3 which will kind of ruin
white's pawn structure
but even more dangerous is knight to f4
so this would probably be
uh the the position that would happen
you're threatening knight to d3 check
and alireza would have to give out the
bishop nipple wins the bishop fair but
maybe queen to e2 next to castle
queenside and the the game continues but
alireza prefers bishop captures on f6
queen captures on f6 and now bishop
captures on d5 so by doing this instead
of that alireza wins the d5 pawn but is
it a pawn he can keep because if he can
keep this pawn and let's say trade down
uh then he has to connect uh then he has
a past d-pawn and a very strong um uh uh
c pawn uh so as you can start pushing
them and either create a past c pawn or
just continue pushing your past deep on
could be very very scary so bishop
captures knight captures attacking the
queen queen to g5 now still keeping an
eye on this e3 square everything is just
piling up on that e3 will be pushed at
some point and here alireza just plays
c4 he says i'm not worried about
anything here and jan plays bishop to f4
now even
even better probably is knights to f4
again you are going for that beautiful
d3 square you can deliver a check here
you can deliver a check here and if
captures captures
then we would get this position and now
for example if queen to a2 uh trying to
keep an end e3 square of course if e3
now we can always play f3 so that's
always possible uh but uh jan would play
rook to c8 rook eat a d8 and then he
would have a very nice defense against
those pawns uh however here he decided
to play bishop to f4 first uh and then
now alerissa plays queen to b3 and
though spent some 15 minutes in this
position uh queen to e2 again seems to
be the safest choice because that e3
square is just something that you have
to keep an eye on uh but uh even though
the uh queen guards the the e3 square
from b3 it's not as good as you'll see
so here e3
should be played
but if
if you play it then for example if
capture is an e3 and if bishop captures
we're just going to play king to d1 and
it's still not all that clear how black
will
uh
how black will do do any damage here uh
so instead of this uh after queen to b3
we have h5 nipple says there's a time
for that e3 move let's improve the
position uh e even more so knight to e3
now alerza does not allow the e3 pawn to
be pushed uh queen to h4 and now you
have to be careful if the queen moves
from the defense of the knight just
bishop captures an e3 as the f1 is
pinned so g captures on h5 first all it
is is all right
first
capture that pawn with the queen so your
queen goes to uh uh not uh not as great
a square so queen captures on h5 and now
queen to d1 now already offers a queen
trade uh but ian did not give up a pawn
to at the trade queens here so he plays
queen to h6
uh keeps the pressure bishop captures on
e3 always a threat uh so here we have
knight to f5 again queen to e2 that was
in the air but this queen to e2 is in
the air for the entire game now the
queen on h6 is attacked with queen to h7
and now queen to g4 putting more
pressure on the position so now uh
it's definitely both of them who have to
be careful but maybe even more so young
and here he plays rook to a6 again he
wants um uh to activate his rook again
more control here maybe you can put the
rook to e6 rook to f6 as an idea
but
even instead of rook to a6 e3 e3 just
for for the entire game is just very
very powerful for example if f captures
bishop captures and king d1 now we're
gonna play rook a to d8 and it's um
no one would really want to play this
with white it looks very very scary but
again king the c2 and it seems you are
uh you are okay uh so instead after
queen to g4 we have rook to a6 uh and
now king to d1 well it is a starts uh
running with the king but still knight
to e3 always an idea so it seems like
for the entire game knight knight should
be on e3 and if it's not uh you should
just push e3 but both of them are saying
no we are stronger than that the threat
is always stronger than the execution
uh unless it's not but here that they
are convinced that it is so here we have
rook to f6 by on uh and rook to e1 now
uh you could also guard the e3 square
with rook to a3 and maybe try and keep
the rook on h1 uh for the moment maybe
h4 h5 is an idea but okay uh they are
getting very low on time and uh well
it's only moved 30 they have to reach
more 40 to gain additional time or to
reach time control so here knight to f8
now threatening to pick up the knight
and the knight back to e3 what do you
know uh bishop back to b8 um here okay
uh you have to you have to move the
bishop somewhere but also bishop to h6
might be an idea
put pressure on this f2 pawn but nepal
prefers this b8 square uh and the
situation on the clock if you guys are
interested in alireza is on 10 minutes
never some 11 minutes on the clock 10
more moves
to reach time control so queen back to
e2 and now queen the h4 uh putting even
more pressure on this f2 pawn so rook to
f1 and now rook to f3
so the h3 pawn can be captured but a
nipple first decides to increase the
pressure even further king to c2 and now
comes knight to e6 and this is now very
very dangerous if the knight comes to f4
then the queen is attacked and you can
come to d3 it's just a whole mess so all
it is i can't really allow this he plays
knight to d5 and he has some five
minutes on the clock nepo has some eight
minutes on the clock and now we have
knight to g5 here again for some reason
uh nepo just doesn't play the move
everyone uh else would play uh so rook
captures on h3 is fine he probably
doesn't want to give alireza a moment's
rest for example to consolidate it with
rook rook 81 but e3 is again in the
position and it's such a such a cool
move that um
it's a very hard to
fight against uh now the d4 pawn is
hanging uh also you you can never play f
captures this because rook to h2 just uh
wins the queen uh
a complete mess of a position but here
at knight to g5 by nipple and now we
have rook 8 to e1 again you could also
consider rook to a3 but you could
consider many things i will show it
because you guys enjoyed so much for
example rook captures on a3 knight
captures and now queen captures on h3
now we play knight back to b5 and if
queen to f3 then we trade captures
captures and you you you play the same
game so definitely something to be
considered but instead after knight g5
we have rook a to e1 by alireza and now
rook to e6 you can see that um
if uh if you know things go wrong let's
say if this knight moves from g5 you can
always play queen captures on f3 uh give
up the queen for for two rooks um this
would also come with check it would be
not something maybe yeah you want to do
so rook here uh the the pawn now nicely
defends the rook but also you can shift
to the rook quickly to the g file to the
h file or wherever the rook is needed
knight to d back the c three by already
and now rook e to f6 putting more
pressure on this f2 pawn knight to d1
now adding
more defense to the f2 pawn and now we
have rook 3 to f4 here again nip was
being nipple he just
makes room for this knights to jump to
f3 but there really is no reason uh for
for delaying the capture of the h3 pawn
but nipple is just the the kind of
player who does this even if uh if you
remember watching the world championship
match against magnus carlsen there were
these moments where nipple could just
grab a pawn retain a better position but
he chose not to do it but that's why
i guess he's the most unpredictable
player in the in the top ten
and the one that can play with such
weirdness and still play absolute
brilliant chess so instead rook the f4
by nipple
and now we have a queen to e3 and here
alireza made his 40th move so time
control has been reached but his
position is not that
that great however i will show you uh
just a disgusting engine line defense
for alireza uh that starts with c5 i
mean
what is this who who would play this
point is that after knight to f3 going
after the rook which is um and the best
idea for nipple you're just gonna play
king b1 but i mean c5 plus king to b1
the the
who who does such things knight captures
on e1 rook captures now okay you can
contest this with b6 knight beat the c3
you just don't care you say uh sorry not
knight d knight b to c3 you just say
black has nothing here and after b
captures on c5 you're gonna play queen
to b5 attack the bishop this would come
with check so once the bishop moves now
you capture this attack the bishop uh so
first we're gonna play rook to f5 so the
pawn cannot capture the bishop but queen
to e8 with check bishop to f8 and now
quantus c6 we already have a nice pass
pawn on c6 this would be compensation
enough for alireza but
uh in severe time trouble uh of course
you do not have time to calculate c5
plus king to b1 so i'll play the
uh
the queen to e3 idea uh and uh now comes
knight to f3 just attacking the rook and
this is uh quite sufficient of course
you cannot save the rook because then
just queen captures on h3 and there is
no square for this rook the height
because knight controls uh e1 and g1
queen controls h1 so this is basically
resigns so all it is it starts pushing
the pawn d5 and okay we have bishop to
e5 by nipple uh now comes c5 already
says all right there's not all that much
for me to do i have these pawns let's
let's push them uh and now finally
nipple grabs the rook um
on on e1 with check but even this can be
delayed um for example rook to h6 is a
beautiful move but an incredible and
incredibly difficult one to spot point
is that after let's say king to b1 you
capture on h3 now and the point is now
you don't have rook to h1 because black
gladly gives up the queen here and well
the knight is hanging so uh if you
defend it let's say knight to c3 we play
rook to e1 attack the queen after queen
c1 we play rook h4 play the rook to h1
and the white is just busted so after
this queen captures an h3 move rook to
h1 not really an option you're gonna
have to keep uh running away now queen
d7
uh that's uh sort of uh sort of the idea
putting pressure on the d-pawn and after
d6 we're just gonna play rook to h3 and
this is the position that would be just
beautiful beautiful for uh for nipple
but okay here he played knight captures
and he won right away this comes with
check rook captures on e1 and now rook
captures on f2 uh he gives up gives up
the exchange uh back knight captures on
f2 and now we don't have rook captures
on f2 but again therefore being nepo
rook to f3 uh and here it's uh i think
it's a good idea that he's just being
himself because if you play rook
captures on f2 which is pretty much an
automatic for everyone let's say rookie
2 rook captures queen captures now queen
f4 looks like a great position for black
but d6 for example we have e3 now
opening up all of these
possibilities that start checking the
white king b3 we defend the a4 pawn
we're going to play queen e4 check let's
say queen to d3 now queen to g to check
king to d1 and now after let's say queen
f3 checking c1 and bishop f4 threatening
this discovery uh we play king the c2
and uh there's
there doesn't seem to be a good way to
push if we just push then the queen is
lost so you have to move the queen first
not just king d1 and you keep an eye on
this square so it's a it's a very tricky
position uh whether it would uh it's
winning it's hard to say uh if if black
makes even a slight imprecision and this
pawn gets to d7 uh then there is no no
more winning chances and you you might
even be be in some trouble so here uh
rook captures on f2 is the engine's
absolute main choice but i think nepo
does the correct move uh
in going after rook to f3 instead
and now what he wanted was for our
leaders that the play queen captures on
e4 but he was able to confuse all it is
a queen captures on e4
is the best move but it does seem like
an it's it's an incredibly difficult one
to hold rook captures on f2 with check
king d1 now queen h5 check rook to e2
and now bishop captures on b2 and it
looks absolutely disgusting we have
complete pressure here uh we've just
grabbed another pawn the material is
completely equal
but uh
after something like c6 white definitely
has counter play let's say rook captures
queen captures so you can play queen
captures on d5 with check king c2 let's
say b captures on c6 now attacking the
knight here king captures here c
captures on b5 and after let's say queen
eight check king h7 and a captures on b5
you get a nice pass pawn and white has
all the compensation white needs okay
you can play a fourth threat and some
queen to b3 ideas uh but it's nothing uh
queen c6 queen b3 cher king a1 and
there's no way for uh for black to put
this if a3 trying to checkmate queen e4
chuck you always have um uh whatever
perpetual you want there's there's just
no way you're gonna lose this so uh
queen captures an e4 uh does uh work for
white but it seems that um uh nipple
managed to confuse aliereza completely
and alireza says all right you didn't
win back the piece i'm just gonna play
knight captures on e4 and sacrifice the
queen so we've basically reached the
position from the thumbnail now the real
question is uh can nipple actually win
this end game he grabs the queen rook
captures on e3 rook captures on e3 and
now even though we've gained additional
time the situation is 13 minutes for
nipple uh for all it is and nine minutes
for nipple uh now comes f5 and that's
that's the good stuff the a4 pawn might
might fall so knight eat the c3 we
defend it and now bishop captures on c3
forcing uh the knights to capture you
don't want the knight here helping out
with the advancement of these pawns so
here knight captures on c3 and now uh
it's a it's a very tricky position
there's only one move that wins the game
for uh for nipple so feel free to pause
the video and try to find this uh
unimaginable idea
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting uh this
uh
uh incredible idea and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
queen to f2 check
that's right this is one of the very
rare puzzles where where the solution
will start with check on this channel uh
but uh it is the only move that wins the
game for jan and it it has a very clear
purpose now if the rook moves for
example rook to e2 we just pick up the
c5 pawn and then you are very
unlikely to to be able to push
for anything here because those two
pawns are your only shot at
gaining anything from the game so here
queen to d3 was played but now f4 and we
force the rook to move away and here we
have rook to e4 rook to e8 check is very
interesting but we're just going to play
king to h7 and there's uh no good
continuation here if knight e4 guarding
uh guarding the spawn uh there's even
queen f1 check king d4 queen to d1 check
now you either move and we start winning
some material or you go forward and then
queen to h5 check picks up the rook so
there's no way to
actually do this it's a it's a it's it's
an open board
and the queen can just deliver checks
from so many different uh uh uh squares
so here rookie four trying to give up
the c5 pawn but now uh nipple not
interested in that just a queen g3 check
and that was the whole point uh of um of
the the maneuver you want to have a
perfect position to start pushing your f
pawn so it can be faster than uh it is a
d pawn and this is definitely the case
now of course this is impossible the
coupon covers this square
so king d2 now comes pawn to f3 we have
d6 now alireza also starts pushing the
pawn if the pawn reaches d7 then we are
very close to the promotion but alireza
has only one minute on the clock uh plus
also his position is now definitely uh
terrible and now queen to g2 with check
uh now if you just move the king king to
d1 f2 and there's no defense against f1
uh so here alireza tries one last idea
knight to e2
but nepo doesn't even react to this he
just plays f2 now he's preparing to
bring the queen into the game uh rook
the e8 with check king f7 and now rook
to e7 check here nepal played king to f6
and he was in this position on move 55
that uh alireza firuja resigned the game
as there is nothing more uh to be done
here uh next move f1 uh comes uh
a queen
comes into the game you cannot push the
pawn because the rook would hang and
also the king then covers the d8 square
so there is really nothing you can do
here and um okay uh the king does belong
on fa not another on f6 for example if
rook to e8 uh you might want to meet
pawn to f1 with check and then trade
rook for queen but still it's a
completely lost game it would just last
longer so here you would have to repeat
king f7 and then put a king on f8 and
then it really is over if if knight to
f4 going after the queen uh just queen
to g5 uh
now there's really nothing if if king
here we're gonna capture here king f1
but that's just it queen h2 and okay uh
this is now an overkill no no point in
going any further with this so after
king to f6 alireza resigned and it would
seem that uh his first classical game
upon reaching the 2800 club uh kicks
alireza right out of the 2800 club on
the live ratings list of course
uh as the tournament is still uh going
on he will have a chance to to bounce
back and re-enter the club uh but for
now i think he's on some
27-97 or something like that
uh so yeah uh
incredible game i hope you guys enjoyed
it all it is a really really prepared
well he found that beautiful game that
nepal played against karjakin uh in the
in the norway chess armageddon game uh
he he tried to push he uh for the entire
game he didn't want a castle castling
queenside uh was always
a pretty good idea if he decided to go
for his queen to eat to move castle's
queen side while while it was still
possible
but he kept his king in the center of
the board he just started pushing his
spawns and it seems like okay it's maybe
something only an engine would be able
to do he tried playing the absolute best
chess possible uh but against the player
like like kanye pomeshi that is uh that
is a very very tough gambit to pull off
and here uh it is it is a nipple who who
emerges victorious uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoy the story about
the video taking a bit longer it is a
classical game and so much stuff was
happening so we had to show a few extra
lines
uh so i
hope you don't mind uh i would like to
thank michael calvert asher fine joshua
hadley queen c and bonifate alberto for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this wonderful tournament
until it finishes so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day